And now, dear friends,
it is time for tonight's
motivational #HashtagWars.
(cheering)
This time of year,
every gossip Web site is filled
with already skinny celebrities
talking about how they just want
to lose enough weight to fit
safely inside the overhead bin.
-You know what I mean.
-(laughter)
So to show our support
for their struggle this year,
tonight's hashtag is
#HealthierCelebs.
Examples might be--
Morgan Gluten-Freeman,
and Jacked Black.
I'm gonna put 60 seconds,
and begin.
-Marcella.
-Flaxl Rose.
Points.
-Affion.
-Kale Earnhardt Jr.
Points.
-Marcella.
-Vitamin CeeLo.
Points.
-Amanda.
-Meek Treadmill.
Points.
-Marcella.
-Sarah Jessica Parkour.
Points! Very good!
Affion.
-Brad Fit.
-Yup. Points.
-Marcella.
-Denzel Flossington.
Points.
-Amanda.
-Meghan Personal Trainor.
Yes, points! Very good.
-Marcella.
-Organicki Minaj.
-Yes, points. That's great.
-(whooping)
-Affion.
-Chris Rock Hard Abs!
Yeah, points.
-Amanda.
-Lupita Bread Nyong'o.
Yes, points.
-Marcella.
-Bernie Macrobiotic.
Points.
-Amanda.
-Tofu Grace.
Yes, points. Very good.
-Affion.
-Drake weight.
(laughter)
I just wanted to do this.
It was funny.
Points. Amanda.
The artist
formerly known as Sprints.
Yes, points.